yeah but i totally get it yeah yeah
because he's like a professional athlete
yeah he looks probably like delicious
you know what i mean yeah yeah
delicious
yeah he can't believe it and he saw a
photo of me just don't tell you
something this is the only reason why
she did that
like at first she didn't really like you
she just wanted to the biggest [ __ ] you
to him ever
is let me let me find the most
disgusting
and then what happened was she was like
yeah i see something right now
she was like oh because i really
i mean look at your face look how
offended he got
look at this he's the ugliest black dude
i've ever seen
anyway let's move on i like you thanks
for doing the podcast i appreciate it
i'm just saying doing the podcast can
you just admit to him that that was
but it was a fluke
ask her why she's dating me
we just did i just answered all she
answered questions we know why she
wanted to get back at her professional
absolute boyfriend
because you grew on her like the mold on
your foot yes her shallowness was like
you know what she said to herself you
know what i'm i don't need attractive
anymore yeah i don't need tall i don't
need anybody that can protect me in an
alley i don't need anybody that can get
things off the top shelf
you know yeah i don't need anyone that
knows how to use a toilet properly or
hasn't i just how it goes eric so he
didn't need to yeah do you get a lot of
girls
what are you trying to say
no i'm asking you you look like a [ __ ]
slayer
i'm just asking you look i i can't trust
anything you say because you're with
bobby
so any compliments you give me i'm like
oh
you get a lot do you think that my
stocks as a woman are down totally down
because i've i've dated bobby for three
years no no i don't think so
i feel like bobby's
i mean i don't know what you want me to
say right now
how about you be honest i mean your guys
trapped i'm trapped it was like let's
suppose this relationship ends and i
date the next guy who's an attractive
guy and i'm really into him and i say
hey
you know my ex-boyfriend is bobby lee do
you think that in his mind my stock's
just nothing in his mind his stock is
going to drop
he's going to be like i can't what
bobby it's like when you go to work i'm
going to say this right now
you know what
i want to say this right now okay you
literally oh
black version of me
all right oh no not at all yeah you
don't look like chris spencer so we're
funny
that's how angry funny
angry funny and charming what yeah yeah
i bobby i know what i'm working with
yeah you do right okay and i know what
i'm working with and we're the same no
not really why we pull both we both play
the video games
like [ __ ] 12 year olds but i'm
tall can reach things on the higher your
shot you're bad yeah but that can change
that you haven't but i can
i did three years ago i had a trainer i
know but i can but here's the thing i
can always go back you're always going
to be you're looking like a hair like a
pear
why are you so mad i don't know why i'm
so angry right now but the thing is is
that um
i know but
and i'm visualizing i heard something um
through the grape i don't know i don't
wanna hear it i don't wanna talk about
any of this step it up i i heard
something through the grapevine and then
not necessarily from your brother i
don't know you've been lying
to all of us
all these years all 50 episodes of this
podcast you've been lying about what
you said that you've only sucked dick
and it turns out you've actually
[ __ ] before and you've been
[ __ ]
who said that
i heard from a little birdie that you in
fact have [ __ ] and have been
[ __ ] okay
okay i want to ask you this right now
who the [ __ ] this little birdie i
don't know because i'm gonna tell you
right now there's only one little bird
i don't know any kind of information and
that little birdie seems to be in this
[ __ ] room
no i didn't say nothing
did you tell us i butt [ __ ] and i got
my butt but i got [ __ ] up
did you tell her that dude we should
switch topics
did you tell her that i don't know i'm
not saying steve you don't have to claim
is this proper like podcast topics yeah
yeah yeah yeah i mean i thought we were
going to talk about game of thrones and
launch today
that apparently you weren't in
elementary school this was in high
school i was in high school
middle school i don't wanna i'm not
gonna say anything was in high school i
don't know i don't i'm trying to forget
that
it wasn't high school
look at me right now dude it wasn't high
school i don't know i'm all right it was
so long it was so long
no i haven't you penetrated that's from
his mouth
yeah let me see something that whatever
comes out of his mouth is suspect oh no
not in i i believe anything my lips
let's buy guns that's right let's buy
guns
because let me say this a little birdie
you're the little birdie stick yeah yeah
let's see this little birdie okay all
right let's not i'm not gonna say no no
no where are you
ufc
conor mcgregor you tell a story on stage
and whenever you tell it i say to myself
i don't remember that okay i can tell
you exactly i'm going to just say
yeah so okay i will tell you if i bring
steve
on stage he'll go that guy
we're driving to palm springs
just listen okay
because you're already trying to cut the
legs i'm not cutting the legs
250 people
okay a night yep
strangers yep
that we did a gig in palm springs he was
driving just let me finish wrong already
all right fine let me finish
you looked in back at me and i was
masturbating in the car yep nope
no i feel like that's everybody's story
of you there's no here's exactly what
happened i'll tell you bobby picked me
up in his car okay
pick me up his car we were gonna go due
to sandy shore had a room that she was
running at the whatever fantasy springs
casino do you want to come open for me
wonderful i probably worked at the store
for about
two months at this time he picks me up
we're driving because we had to stop at
the bank first unorganized bobby he goes
reaching the back because i have a
couple checks on the floor
i reach in the back on the floor i
remember this or two checks from mad tv
for like whatever
thousands of dollars with footprints
right footprints on the top of them he
collects those puts him into the bank
right now we're dry i have never been
anywhere besides los angeles we're
driving and you i start to see those
spinning things right and we're talking
about you know he's smoking cigarettes
he's got the window open and i'm seeing
and i'm kind of just zoning out out the
window and i wasn't asleep but i was
going out and i look over i come back
and he's got a cigarette and he's got
his pants are open and his hands are in
his pants
and look maybe it wasn't jerking off but
he was comfortable enough
to un
sheath himself
himself pull out his penis which i saw
it wasn't like he was masked and
maybe not pleasure himself to the point
of ejaculation but but
move it around to make it much more
comfortable and i will dare say
pleasurable for you am i incorrect in
any of them let me ask you a question
can i ask you a question sure sure whose
car was it your car exactly yes whose
gig was it your gig exactly i'm not
saying there's anything what country do
we live in your country not my country
we live in the united states of america
okay yeah the land of the [ __ ] free
yes all right yep and so
i could have been masturbating i could
have been itching my [ __ ] sack you
don't [ __ ] know sir absolutely
you're right it's no right for you to
tell in front of 200 [ __ ] 50 people
that i was masturbating and then you
made a joke about it what's the joke the
punch line
tell them the punchline put on some
kenny g or something yeah no because you
asked me you go you could say you asked
me you go what are you doing this is how
i relax and then you say in the in
you're on stage no i just put on some
kenny g or something
i believe you and the reason i believe
you
is because it's this [ __ ] been
out here
i mean you can't say you can start with
me one time
let me ask you another thing last week
we had a couple weeks ago we had jade
counterpredator
and they
you know jade's like yeah mommy
takes me out to dinner and stuff
and i wrap i pay for dinner short time
then i wrap it up to take it home and i
i won't let them
do you know why why it's mine
oh so wait you won't you won't let them
take their own meals home leftovers so
oh my god hold on
okay ready yeah let's just pretend that
instead of this podcast we're out to
dinner right yeah yeah okay you and you
the check comes and you generously pay i
pay here we go
we all have our like i have my to go
thing i got riggatoni with whatever
right right meat sauce
sir
it's the rigatoni the leftover that i
wrapped up for me leave it on the
table what
yeah did you pay for it
no you paid exactly so it's mine
[Laughter]
you want me to
leave it on the table okay there you go
and that's one of the
what that's one of the most monstrous
things i've ever seen it's one of the
most terrible displays
this is how this is how long you've been
in hollywood that you're [ __ ]
what if your mind is your mind has been
poisoned okay
here's what i would do if you did that
to me once i would generously you know
probably 100 right and then the next
time yeah i would i would say i'm done
with my food right yeah then i would
take my food yeah
and when you went to the bathroom i'd
mash it up with my hands yeah
and i'd rub it in my balls and
everything and then i would have them
wrap it up and then i would generously
again hand it to you yeah but the thing
is no here's the thing eat all of this i
understand
so disgusting
but can i say this i don't take the food
home either
what do you do with the food we leave it
there he just throws it with what
so
not uh
what do you do with it there's so many
answers that were that like give it to a
homeless shelter nope give it to my cat
you know what do you know why nothing
because they didn't thrown away they
didn't pay for it the homeless people
it's mine
it's yours to do whatever you want with
it and throw it away that's what like
society time like in the game of thrones
for in
world right you're in a village can i
buy a potato
yeah you buy the potato yeah itchy
[ __ ] your potato dog
yeah but you're not
shut the [ __ ] up now it would take me a
dragon throw it out do you see a dragon
fly by okay just you know certainly yeah
all right khaleesi khaleesi's up there
and then i i go okay can i buy two
potatoes you want some one yeah please
thank you take a bite
okay can i have it back are you done
no
are you done
you want more i thought i i might want
more a little later no no give me the
potato
can i ha can i bring it home with me in
case i'm hungry later on no no no give
me wouldn't that be that no no you
bought the potato for me
bro that's one of the most disgusting
displays of humanity i've ever seen
wasted so paying for somebody's meal is
disgusting that should be
it's just so that you can make people
leave their food mm-hmm
it's a power movement
do you think i'm a good person i really
do i feel good thank you but
with with horrible habits it's not
horrible that's really and when we one
day you and i will go out we'll have a
meal and i will explain to you why
and then you will get it
i mean what if i ordered a bottle of
wine
would you just take the wine and pour it
onto the table if you ordered a bottle
of wine yeah right
here's when we did the scenario earlier
here's the one thing that you missed
what was it what the very first scenario
night when we acted out with gilbert
okay
you boxed it without even asking me
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute hold on hold on
i have my meal in front of me my meal
at this point from when i when i order
my meal
it is my my meal this is my area if you
want to come into it
you have to ask me right
so if someone says to me the waiter
would you like that that wrapped up
would you like your you're asking me
would you like your possession wrapped
up and to take home to your house oh
you're the way i would say something
you're the winner
you tell that to steve all right here's
your check you know sir would you like
me to wrap up your two potatoes
sir
okay
i'm sorry ask me because i paid for it
but he was eating the potato i know but
i paid for it and you as you know i give
you the credit card yes and i gave you a
forty dollar tip which is just like that
sixty dollar tab so i i think you should
ask you know what i take it back because
you're good
we're not done from this [ __ ]
scenario go go ahead sir i'm i'm sorry
uh would you like me to wrap up potato
okay no
i can't wrap your potato sir where do we
at time-wise
what do we have time we're over an hour
great great this is where we are yeah
this is where we know this is what
happens now okay
first of all can i say this hold on
usually they ask you if you want it
wrapped up before they bring the checks
yeah i've wrapped it up and now you
don't own it yet now you're gonna pay
for it just to take my thing yeah [ __ ]
you you [ __ ] you
no no
all right [ __ ] you we do a email
questions no there are nice people off
stage i just didn't get any compliments
and are you exaggerating this
i'm glad i'm glad he did that i'm glad
he challenged me in that way just now
because now you get to see how he is
how are you now you get to see what i
have to deal with
now you get to see it excuse me back up
back up back up right yeah yeah
yo yo
yo man what
let me tell you something dude
i uh
i'm an honest person dude
right and uh
i live life
and experience things right right with
my soul right right and my senses
and i perceive it in the most honest way
and i relay it in the most honest way
and for you to challenge me like that in
front of my own so you're not so you've
never been
a little neurotic
yes all right so that's okay okay is
that what you're saying yeah yeah yeah
i'm neurotic he creates problems in his
mind yeah sometimes yeah yeah whoa
my neurosis yeah
okay
let me say something right now right
last night i did the improv i did all
weekend at the urban improv right
and
i know
i know that i'm
good i know that my show was good
and i know that when people say man that
was a great show
i i can i go i know
i really genuinely know all right
there are times when you see me in the
original room where where i am a little
neurotic because you're compe you're
like it's more of a competition right
there's a lot of comics there
you don't want to you know you just want
to save face right but in this [ __ ]
circumstances south [ __ ] africa bro
right is the real legit [ __ ] thing
man all right so don't [ __ ] challenge
me [ __ ] so i can't ask you a question
you can ask me anything about about if
your neurosis came into play okay maybe
maybe it was a factor a little bit but
my point is this
is this
[Laughter]
all right man you're right i'll change
yes
no i really did experience that and i
got mugged there too get the [ __ ] out of
here yeah i got money are you sure
wow
you you will build up the soil i don't i
would never take sole responsibility for
this whole thing so the
the board of directors the people i have
like sort of advising wait wait wait
stop stop
now i'm scared we could be on the
chopping
board of the directors
they have a [ __ ] board of directors
babe
we didn't know i didn't [ __ ] know it
oh it said there's a pool
look at me right now dude there's a
[ __ ] board all right
all right who is it
okay first of all i'm gonna get the
toughest one out of the way yeah it's
ari shafir yes
a piece of [ __ ] this is a long time ago
all right
i'm not scared now babe no
you should never be boom shakalaka is he
on the board
people don't know him but he's a
homeless
comedian no bert cricher okay tom segura
dave anthony
okay
it's random whatever all right yeah bill
yeah myself all right so when the board
get together you guys get together in a
conference room we have you have yes and
then where do you guys go we gotta let
some of these go well there's certain
people that aren't trying at it very
hard at all so they don't record
and they so they have podcasts but
they're just and they use the studio
occasionally
and that's what we just decided to cut
off
and then how who calls them i had to
make those calls
you're the oh you're the phone call well
let me answer this though
the people that you called are you
friends with them yeah so you know them
yes so i'm okay i don't want to know the
names
i know you're not going to tell me i'll
find out i'm going to find out
so let's say you you're calling me you
have to call let's say you have to let
go of tiger belly okay can i let's know
this act it out can i just well happily
i'll tell you exactly how that goes
because i used to do this little back is
that i used to do this for a living my
parents own a staffing company so at 19
years old i fired my first person
i fired a 22 year old file clerk i
almost just spacing on her name
you don't give a [ __ ]
and i fired over a thousand people
wow
you are he's addicted to firing guys if
you saw george uh clooney that george
clooney movie uh i'm dying not uh up in
the air up in the air yeah i'm up in the
air that's i used to do that yeah whoa
so you're good at it i i'm very sincere
all right ring ring i'm picking up okay
hey hey bobby what's up what's up
uh hey i'm calling about um just real
quick it i get
well unfortunately we made a decision uh
who's we
the board the board let's see all their
names okay yeah okay the board made you
know the board is i know what the board
yeah ari
yeah anyway what happened uh well you
guys aren't recording
we are every oh yeah we're not you're
not in this
off in this scenario
yeah yeah recording and then you know
it's uh it's a lot of resources are
being spent which is like it's best to
go here but there's other stuff you can
do and we'd happily keep you on as a
member
that's hollywood hearsay um
you're saying um yeah you know what
we've known each other for a very long
time
it's really [ __ ] up that you would
call me in this way you also use it real
quick you said real quick yeah i'm done
you're done all right
you know what i'm done too bye
hung up yeah we're done we would never
have our relationships our relationship
and um thank you so much for having me
on your network oh my god tiger bellies
thank you thank you
tell the board the board
i'm appreciative we appreciate it and
i'm grateful tiger bellies uh i told you
guys that we want to do more with i mean
we're looking forward to doing a lot of
big things have you guys announced the
other thing
no that's what i'm making yeah let's
announce but you know what dude um at
the end of the day we'll be fine
nothing's happening
right now no look at me right now never
would be
even if worse comes to worse
just shut up for a second all right look
at me right now i love it just look at
me right now and let me just say what
i'm gonna say and just you could take it
for what it is i don't like all right
but
you can tell the board that we're
grateful just listen okay everyone loves
you but i know that's fine right but
we'll be fine
you're like robert
my little crew here my little crew here
we got it these are fine all right you
can take whatever that is know what i
mean but i don't like your threats
i don't like i don't like so many i
really don't i don't like what you're
doing right now with like the board and
billboard chrysler and all those [ __ ]
guys all right you just don't go [ __ ]
yourselves no if you don't want us
i'm saying right now no we're grateful
and yet we'll be fine you're not good
and you will make bobby a board member
no [ __ ] that no
no i don't want to be a board member but
and i just tell the board this all right
i respect them but i'm not afraid no
no everyone i am not afraid of everyone
okay
i'm not afraid no everything okay sorry
you came by it's a very positive don't
even don't even talk to him right now
because he's doing his [ __ ] thing the
corporate thing george no george let it
go all right we're all magical sure very
hard but why do you guys why don't you
listen to me though what do you mean
just stop for a second i'm gonna stand
up again okay gustav with the camera
stop him
get my ass
it's very handsome i [ __ ] told you
two [ __ ] days ago yes to watch a
documentary because we're going to
[ __ ] talk about it on the [ __ ]
podcast no and you [ __ ] came no let
me that was two days ago [ __ ] not all
right and you did not [ __ ] watch it
okay can i can i count on you something
here you don't have to counter because
what you said earlier yes when you first
came in the [ __ ] house was oh no i
look for it it's on the front page of
all the phones not online not on directv
i didn't have the thing
hbo go or whatever on the [ __ ] ipad i
do have hbo go
i'm going to counter this with something
i'm going to deflect the blame here yeah
and i'm going to call back an episode of
this show that i watched okay where you
i think it was eric stone street and you
admitted to not watching something
mm-hmm
what you're doing it's so cute i thought
about doing that i thought about pulling
a bobby pin i call it ah
it's like crafty is what it is white
crafty it's a white craft music it's
white craft yeah white crap definitely
white minecraft for sure and it's um
shadowplay
brent morin is working in shadow play
and also being white craft
and what it is is this you're twisting
it and you're turning it and you're
right but can i say this like house of
cards
that's a very good [ __ ] point thank
you but can i just say this my friend
yes i'm the [ __ ] captain of the ship
i can tell
okay
and right now when you're in my [ __ ]
submarine mm-hmm it's a submarine oh
it's a submarine yeah you have to run a
ship yeah very colorful
dual purpose it's a dual prop purpose
it comes up and down yeah and right now
it's a silly submarine food you know
i've heard of seeing that spoon
yes it's a sinking submarine right now
because you you you undermine my
captaincy
i thought you know what that might be a
word but what if i said it i don't know
if it is
my captain c captain c
okay probably and we got um a very
special cause we've had them before this
i think this is the first time we've
used no we've used assa a couple times
but this is his um fat lando
i'm not going to do that there's a new
movie called you already clapped star
wars and he's stat lando and um oh i'm
fat landon
there's gonna be
you're fat yoda [ __ ] that's who you are
oh yeah you can't even get on luke
skywalker's back
is like yoda i don't know if i can
how about we walk together bro it's good
it's good it's good
i asked for it i asked for it
yeah
um so we got eric griffin back and uh
he's on a new television program called
i'm dying up here
and it's on show time and uh
and my special comes out july 7. what
are we going to do that [ __ ] dude i'm
sorry
well i don't know don't you blow out
your load it's so unorganized and i'm
not sure
see that's the thing in the chaos
yeah yeah
this is structured river over here i
don't know what it was yeah yeah
and um
when i get my beard transplant which is
what i'm going to do i'm going to use i
told you this i'm going to use your
knuckle hairs
i mean what the [ __ ]
you're going to do that's that's what's
up let me let me [ __ ] mustache you
have on your face are you going to talk
about this [ __ ] let me figure it out you
are outta here
right right let me finish this i know i
do look like i'm in the middle of you
haven't evolved fully you know what i
mean no this is like right before the
werewolf movie right before the guy goes
rotten you know yeah
you don't want to shave that [ __ ] or wax
it i've tried then it turns into your
butthole yeah yeah yeah oh my god that's
so weird i just noticed that yeah it's
really bad because you're such a big guy
that there's just so much to look at
here we go so i just i slowly noticed
first of all bobby per capita you're way
fatter you know what it means
like if you did like proportionally yeah
proportionally yeah you're just like
okay okay see this is don't make fun of
me
every day every day this time
yeah yeah
i mean her and i the other day we try to
make love in from the dog it doesn't
work can i tell you why it didn't
what in god's name do you mean my friend
i'm just saying it's like a cabbage
patch doll
there you go that's all that's all i
want to know
i get what you're saying right now a
barbie
and how does it work okay let me just
say is
there's a stick there's a hole right no
i can figure it out
yeah okay there's angles there's
different ways to go in let's say the
hole
he's like four feet higher
[Laughter]
come on man then you just do
um
so i want to hear about the dog [ __ ]
let me hear you
okay so
i go
did anyone come no one no she faked it
just a dog i didn't think you go i i you
know i came already i came over here i
go you didn't you don't you don't know
she did it of course